parts of the country's midsection Slam
by days of catastrophic flooding face a
new threat from more rain the region is
bracing for a new round of flooding as
rivers in 40 locations rise to historic
levels flood watches and warnings are in
effect in more than a dozen states at
least three deaths are blamed on the
disaster more than 70 cities in Nebraska
are under emergency declarations today
this is the worst flooding the state has
seen at least half a century Vice
President Mike Pence will survey the
devastation later today DeMarco Morgan
is in Waterloo Nebraska that's near
Omaha DeMarco good morning to you good
morning to you just take a look at the
damage that has been done to this
highway right here you can see it's
pretty buckled and the conditions
stretch back for about half a mile here
and when you talk about the total of
damage we're talking about hundreds of
millions of dollars and you said it the
threat of flooding continues the views
from the sky over the flooded Midwest
revealed miles and miles of devastation
we took a plane to Fremont a town of
26,000 that is nearly isolated by the
water
volunteers with planes are helping fly
in supplies pretty much landlocked and
you know they're running out of food so
it's just more than happy to help while
on the ground
a convoy led by the Nebraska National
Guard delivered aid along restricted
routes I think it's good to like see the
community come together bringing
supplies in from Omaha since Sunday more
than 4,400 people have been evacuated
from their homes at at least four states
and rising rivers have breached in
nearly 200 miles of levees 55 years I've
never seen anything like this
the devastation could not come at a
worse time for farmers chapter 12
bankruptcies were up nearly 20 percent
last year among Midwest farms at it's
estimated more than 400 million dollars
worth of livestock could be impacted by
the flooding we just had a short time to
get essentials and dogs and us out the
door but the important stuff we got and
the rest will have to be replaced many
who were able to return to their homes
yesterday discovered they've lost
everything I'm just kind of in a fog I
really don't know what we're gonna
but all you can do is pull up your
bootstraps and start over I guess now
the National Weather Service says
historic and catastrophic flooding will
continue for parts of the central plains
and the Upper Midwest as heavy rains and
of course the snowmelt continued now the
mayor Fargo North Dakota is asking
residents there to help fill 1 million
sandbags they're getting ready for major
flooding there as well the community
really coming together devastating
images DeMarco thank you